I have you been
the Super Bowl is one of the biggest
stages in the world yeah it's an
Entertainer's dream to be on a stage
like that Rihanna's shining bright
during her Super Bowl halftime
performance and reminding fans just how
fire her catalog is I'm still pinching
myself really I'm grateful I'm grateful
re even hinted at her second pregnancy
by showing off her baby bump on stage
I'm a Confident Woman so whatever I do
it's gonna make it happen out before
later confirming the big news to ET
she's saying some of her biggest hits
like where have you been and only girl
in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
you only have 13 minutes that's the
challenge so you're trying to cram
17 years of work into 13 minutes so it's
it's difficult yeah the Barbarian Beauty
continued to work when she performed Run
This Town
thank you
[Music]
And We Found Love
ahead of the games kickoff celebs like
Kevin Hart Gayle King and DJ Khaled
raved over Rihanna's performance well
first of all it's uh it's a Rihanna
concert featuring a Super Bowl let's not
let's not get that confused all right it
is an absolute Rihanna show uh the Super
Bowl is the second fiddle to it now I
can't wait for Rihanna I Can't Wait and
I'm saying just can't wait to see the
halftime performance you know it's going
to be the re-re Super Bowl
[Music]
foreign